[Music]
okay everybody so I am honored today cuz
I am joined by Michael mando aka nacho
Varga from better call Saul Michael how
are you doing today how are you Steve so
nice to be on your podcast my friend
yeah man I'm doing good so I wanted to
jump into a scene that really stood out
for me with nacho which was an episode
two where he is in the car with Gus's
henchman and then Gus comes in and they
basically threatened to kill his dad in
front of them it's a gruesome scene it's
terrifying to watch I want to know as an
actor how do you even get to that place
of where nacho is in that scene and get
like all pumped up in a sense well thank
you so much man I really appreciate your
compliment you know what that's rude
that was a really really hard thing for
many reasons the first thing is there's
so many ways to play that scene you know
you could play it incredibly emotional
you could play it detached you could
there's there's a million ways to play
it and I think the challenge of it was
that that we wanted not sure to sort of
subconsciously know that this was not
really going to happen that this was
just a psychologic the way was described
in the script was that it was
psychological torture so it wasn't like
immediate it wasn't it wasn't supposed
to be an immediate threat to his
father's life but in Naturals mind he
was to see what it would feel like was
his father to be assassinated in front
of him and it was a really really hard
thing for me to play because that's the
whole heart of the character he's trying
to save his father and in that moment he
painfully has to watch his reading of
existing basically jeopardized and lose
everything and it's either that or you
know either he does what Gus says or his
father is dead and that really
solidifies the character for me and we
really come to understand that
everything he's doing at this point on
is 100% just to save his father's life
and that he's willing to
all the money in the world all the power
in the world all the influence in the
world and leave it all just so he can
save his father's life of course but it
goes a little deeper than that so that
his father can look at him with respect
and love again and his father of course
is you know the most moral character and
Nacho's universe sort of like a saint if
you will and it's just such a beautiful
really beautiful character and I just
feel so lucky to be a part of it really
yeah that's what I wanted to hit on too
is like you said that his father's like
the heart of this character and you know
there's a scene in episode 3 where he's
sitting with his father who comes to his
house and he's accusing his son of
having someone bribe him basically with
money to get out of town and I just want
to know so you can kind of clear up for
the audience's when the father is like
constantly saying to nacho like get out
of the game start a new life you know
this isn't you what really is stopping
nacho from just leaving the country and
starting a new life like why is he so
just trapped in this hell well it's a
bit more complex I mean you're
absolutely right in what you're saying
but I think in natural situation for him
for nacho is a bit more complex because
not you wasn't bribing his father not
what natural did was natural sense an
old friend an old family friend he gave
an old family friend money to buy up his
father's shop and offered him a really
good deal and his father found out
because his father's pretty smart and
kind of I guess knows the son that the
money that the guy was buying the store
with was nachos money and that it was
natural way of liberating his father
from his shop so that his father is now
mobile and he can run away with his
father the reason why he not sure can't
leave is because the moment nacho
disappears they're going to go after his
father so it is absolutely important
that naturally with his father but his
father doesn't want to leave and his
father's solution is father's solution
is go to the police and of course not
you can't do that because if it's not
sure what's to go to the police that
means he's going to have to testify
again
the whole cartel and that means that
they're actually definitely going to
kill his father at that point and him
and everybody who tries to testify but
his father has such a I guess a
black-and-white sense of morality that
he doesn't understand the complexity of
this underground world that it deals
with people that go up into government
you know it's not just like you know
pigs on the corner of the street you
know this is we're talking about
incredibly powerful people who have
connections in the military you know Gus
fring has connections in Europe he runs
one of the biggest you know fast food
chains in that part of the world and not
to really I mean it's it's it's
unbelievable because he really finds
themselves in this in this in this
situation that really feels impossible
yeah and that's I think the just hard
thing about watching this whole
storyline unfold would not Joe and I
really hit me to an episode three where
we were back at nachos house and like it
reminds me a lot a bit of Jesse
pinkman's story where it's like you have
this really nice house there's beautiful
woman big TV big paintings but there's
like literally visually no light in that
place it's just hollow and like dark and
I was wondering like do you find any joy
in the character of nacho or is he just
always at like a mute sad place you know
it's funny there's I feel so much
compassion for the character and it's so
much love you know I for me it's a
redemption story you know it's the story
of a young man who got into this
business because it was what was
flashiest you know he felt if I wanted
to make money and drive nice cars and
date a beautiful girl and have big house
with big paintings then this is
available to me and all my friends are
doing it and I'm going to do it and I'm
going to be the best at it and as he
gets involved you know he realizes that
when his father looks at him and
discovers who who he's become there's
this sense of shame you know this
immense sense of you know I at this
point his father comes in and looks at
the painting and naturally just realizes
how stupid
everything looks and and that no money
in the world can earn true respect and
that's what I love about the character
is that he's able to to look at himself
and and realized that he's made a
mistake and his and his sense of
morality kind of increases because
holistic almost you know he realizes
there's much more to life than this and
respect and dignity and integrity and
the right way is way superior than than
all the money in the world and and
that's such an iconoclastic character
and and it's I've never seen a character
like that in recent memory it's usually
the opposite you've got someone who
starts off really good and ends up doing
really bad but in this case if someone
starts off really bad and ends up truly
genuinely wanting to do really good and
he's willing to die for it and it really
warms my heart you know it really really
does I feel lucky I see it was such an
iconoclastic thing to do you know for
those writers death created a character
like that yeah it really is awesome to
just to see you watching like you're
saying it feels fresh and new to see on
TV especially in you know I remember
when I first started watching you in the
show I looked up a couple interviews of
you and I was expecting this guy who was
very like upset and like you will seem
like the nicest dude you have so much
like a bubbly personality
so it's just a credit to how good your
acting is and I just want to know too
how do you turn is like a switch you're
turning on when you're on set to get to
like okay now I'm not sure there's a
very dark character who does seem very
different from you is there like how do
you get to that place all the time well
thank you so much it really means it
means a lot those are very very sweet
words and move by it thank you um you
know I think I feel I mean personally I
don't know if I should say this because
it might make me sound crazy but I feel
like I feel like I can recognize I can
understand I think everybody's emotional
reality and you know I should walk down
the street and we see somebody who's
shooting meth in the corner of the
street and yelling at you I can
understand what would drive someone to
do
and I can understand why someone would
sell drugs I can understand why someone
would be a police officer and stop that
person who wants to sell drugs so I
think it all starts with a certain
degree of compassion for others and this
understanding of like you know had I
done this and that and this has been a
little bit different I would have ended
up here and had I done this and this I
would have ended up here so I think
we're all kind of capable or at least at
least I'd like to think we're all
capable of doing everything and some of
us don't realize we're doing it and then
we catch ourselves and figure out oh my
god what am i doing and then some of us
change and some of us don't what I love
about nacho is that he catches himself
doing that that saying that he's been
doing for a while and it's like he's got
a moment of clarity and I think it takes
an incredible amount of willpower for
character or for a human being to truly
change his life course and this
character is really unique in that sense
so III think I think he is dark but I
think he's heading towards the light and
I think you know he might not make it he
might make it who knows but I think I
hope so that he continues to head
towards the light and if there is an
afterlife you know hypothetically
speaking I think that's where he I think
he may be heading towards a good place
or I think I'd like to think you know
what I mean
sure and do you see any of Michael mando
in the character of nacho the
relationship with his father is very
inspired by the love that I have from my
dad you know I was broan I was raised by
a single father and my dad raised three
boys and I'm the middle one and I've
seen my dad worked so hard and
sacrificed so much to raise three young
kids you know really kind of loud and
you know very competitive and very
athletic and very you know
uncontrollable almost and all this
testosterone in the house and it's only
now that I'm getting older than I
realize how hard it must have been for
my father you know to just be a single
man raising three boys and traveling
with us and putting us through school
and making sure we're fed and putting us
into you know playing hockey
and boxing and football and doing
everything you know giving us everything
he could and I think a lot of that is
inspire inspired me with the
relationship with Juan Carlos cancer who
plays my father and one Connells kind
too and I really hit it off immediately
you know the moment I knew he was
playing my father it was kind of new to
me I didn't didn't really tell me about
it I kind of read the script and said oh
he's got a dad and the moment Juan
Carlos flew into Albuquerque I invited
him for lunch and I said look man I'm
really interested in building a
relationship with the father because I
feel it gives an opportunity to humanize
this archetype that is otherwise a very
stereotypically kind of ruthless right
and who Juan Carlos who is Mexican I'm
not Mexican myself
I'm french-canadian but Juan Carlos is
Mexican and he immediately felt this was
an opportunity for us to kind of flip
the archetype and it started there you
know we one was very touchy you know he
was hugging and you know at some point I
said why don't you give me a little slap
on the cheek and he liked the idea and
he did it and the reason we wanted to do
it is we wanted to show that with around
his spot around his father natural
didn't have any ego there was no alpha
ego there was no like manly kind of like
I'm in control relationship with his
father at all and that that that would
switch when he was alone with Mike and
that gave you an insight that these
people were human beings that were
putting on a character in order to
survive in the jungle and a lot of that
is inspired by you know stuff that I
lived and seen I remember when I was and
I feel like I'm ranking over here like I
hate those things you know you hear
those podcast and you're like man I I
didn't shut up for hours like what the
hell am i is it I'll tell you a quick
story quick anecdote before I stop
ranting though see what the next
questions sir
but I remember I was in Toronto and in
Canada Toronto and I was living in a
place called st. James town and this is
before I wanted to be an
and I love playing basketball and I I
wanted to play but I didn't know anybody
in the neighborhood and it was kind of
like a you know I've lived throughout
the whole Gama of you know poor to
well-off you know we've been poor and we
were well-off I kind of tasted both
sides and at that part in our lives we
were we weren't doing very well
financially and I remember going to see
my dad we were living in this place and
people were selling drugs in the
basketball between basketball between
the game like very nice cars would stop
you see these people from other
neighborhoods and then the guy would run
and sell him something and then come
back and play and it was kind of like
must have been expensive drugs or maybe
not I don't know but the people that
were buying it were definitely well-off
and I really wanted to play basketball
and I was so intimidated you know I said
to myself man these guys not going to
let me play with them you know it's like
super competitive and everybody's
yelling I got next and everybody knows
everybody and I I I don't know what gave
me the idea you know I was a teenager
and I decided I was going to shave my
eyebrows like kind of like vanilla ice
yeah like like make lines in my eyebrows
the mixer look tougher sorry and I
accidentally ended up shaving half of my
eyebrows off and I said to myself you
know what maybe I'll shave the other one
off so that they're both parallel and
they have these very tiny weird eyebrows
off and I went back to the court and I
started walking with a bit of a swagger
and acting a little bit like I was
unstable you know sure and then the
moment the ball kind of bounced in my
corner I took it and just kind of impose
myself on the court and acted like I was
a little bit drunk and started shooting
and kind of posturing like it like it
like it like a gorilla in the jungle you
know yeah and and surely enough I before
you knew when I was playing and and and
that's kind of I think what that is that
that posturing in this underground world
is that you you've got to have that
persona you know and I think nacho has
that persona you
he's learned to not speak a lot and we
learned to hold back and observe and and
that's a persona and then when his
father comes and serving him coffee
that's got to him right and it's kind of
like Saul Goodman you know Saul Goodman
got his persona and Jimmy McGill is is
really who he is I think the major
difference between nacho and his persona
is that they're complete a complete
opposite spectrum morale you know nacho
has a very good moral core but he's in
an environment where his persona is is
doing very immoral things and I think
that's the complexity of the character
is that he doesn't want interesting yeah
that's that's a crazy story - it's
almost like you're doing in that story
what you would do in the future
full-time and just acting and like
performing and yeah I didn't even know I
wanted to be an actor at the time to be
honest to do it yeah because I read a
story if you could tell me this is true
or not but that you suffered a knee
injury in your mid-20s and then like
yeah yeah I had a bullet that went
through mine it kind of missed my main
bones but it's my kind of hit a little
bit this side of it went it went down
through through my calf area oh my god
that's that's insane and so yeah and
then in there Hannah took me on a
journey were I started kind of
questioning my life and it was really
hard because I had to you know I had
trouble at the time walking and they
thought I was never going to play sports
again and they at some point I had an
infection in my bones and they were
going to cut my leg off geez
and I would never forget it I was at the
hospital like 6:00 in the morning and my
father was there with me and and he was
worried and I said just give it to me
straight you know what's going on and he
goes they're gonna call a specialist and
the worst case scenario is that they're
going to cut your leg off oh my god and
I'll never forget it I was you know you
go through something like that in life
and you're sitting there and you
immediately your survival instincts
kicks in and says I said to myself I'm
gonna be a writer
immediately right there on the bed
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna be a
writer and it was weird you know I
wasn't even thinking about like the
complexity of like what if it goes bad
and I die I just thought okay they're
gonna cut my leg off it'll be fine and
then I'll write I didn't think of the
pain that I would go through severely
meeting with families and and those
things I think that's kind of my journey
that sort of in a strange way led me to
acting and now for the first time in my
life I'm going to do music I'm releasing
music
in April April 7th I'm going to release
my first single in it's I think it's you
you get you go through experiences like
that and you say to yourself you know
life is so short yeah man you know what
I've been doing interviews on all
morning
all right and I realize you got me at
that sweet spot where it's like I have
I'm just talking a lot talking and I
can't stop okay so actually to wrap
things up I noticed that
here's more random stuff but you're a
man of many inspirational quotes on
Twitter do you apply mantras to your
life daily are you really into it or do
you bring that to your acting game at
all I try to you know I I really feel
that a craftsman is a noble thing and by
that I mean whether you're you know
whether you're building a table or
you're an electrician or garbageman or a
doctor or a surgeon I mean whatever you
do I think it's important to take a
sense of responsibility and to truly
love what you do and just feel that
you're contributing to society and and
that's what motivates me or else to be
honest with you there are days I don't
feel like doing it there are days I
don't feel like doing an interview I
don't I don't want to go to work - this
morning I don't feel like shooting but
if you in be if you embody a sense of
responsibility and a sense of meaning to
it
then you find then you have a motivation
and when you have the motivation you
have a desire to get better and then you
know everything stems from there so yeah
definitely I always try to find a deeper
meaning to what I'm doing so that I
don't lose
the motivation that I keep that sense of
responsibility and everything and that's
why I don't like to work a lot because I
feel if I if I'm always working if I say
yes to everything then I feel I won't
put in as much effort sure after a while
and it takes so much out of me that I
feel like I'd rather not do a lot and
and do it for a very long time then do a
lot and then feel like I'm just getting
stale and thank God at this point you
know I've been able to find that balance
where every time I go back I'm giving
everything and every time I'm dead a
project I have absolutely nothing listed
years yes that alone right there is just
great wisdom for any field you know for
anyone listening that's brilliant thank
you for that and I'm gonna ask you one
more thing because I'll get killed if I
don't ask this but and you don't have to
answer this because I don't know what
the rules are on this but you know we
saw you in spider-man homecoming at the
end there as a scorpion is there a
chance we'll ever see him again there's
a chance okay that's all that's all I
wanted to go with a pin okay is there
anything else you want to promote
besides a better call Saul before I let
you go yeah I've got some music coming
out in April and my first singles coming
out and I can't wait for the world to
hear and then I'm really really proud of
it it's something that I incredibly
passionate about it's kind of been my
real childhood dream has always been
music it's never been acting okay and
then for me to finally do this just
feels surreal you know to be able to act
and now to be able to release music it's
just you know I just can't wait for the
world to hear it and I hope I hope you
guys like it and we'll be able to find
it under your name I'm like Spotify an
idea it's under Michael Mann it's called
it you'll see it on my social media on
Instagram and I'll be promoting it and
then let me know what you think then I'd
love to get your opinion oh hell yeah
and yeah everyone make sure to check
that out and obviously make sure to keep
watching better call Saul every Monday
9:00 p.m. to see Michael mando dude
nacho Varga on AMC Michael thank you so
much for joining me it's been a pleasure
and I hope to talk to you for season six
thank you so much my friend it's been a
real pleasure
and speak to you soon thanks Michael